what does it mean to really develop a
character boy that's a good question
what does it mean to develop a character
you know I think you need to to
understand the character understand the
way the character thinks often we start
out with you know when you're when
you're looking at it just from this the
nuts-and-bolts story you go okay that's
my villain this is my hero that's the
love interest this is and you come up
with the archetypes and then what we
need to do is shade in those characters
so that they're unlike any other hero
villain love interest you know sidekick
whatever we've seen before there's there
the individual and so when we shade it
in that's the developing the character
we're taking a character it and taking
him from stick figure and shading them
in so they're three-dimensional which
one of the things that I think is
important is to know why your villain is
right and why your hero is wrong or
protagonist and antagonist because often
what happens is people don't know why
their protagonist is wrong their
protagonist is 100% right or why their
antagonist is right you know is is on
the right track and people are
multi-dimensional you know we're not all
good and bad so to find the good in the
bad character in the bad and the good
character are critical to making that a
three-dimensional character and that's a
tough thing for a lot of new writers is
they just want to have their their hero
wants to be there it's it's a as a
projection of themselves they're the
perfect version of themselves the
problem is a perfect person is dull we
like flawed people you know we want my
the example that I always use is liar
liar because Jim Carrey's character is a
bad father and says so and he is a
terrible father now he means to be a
good father but he's not so that
character flaw being the guy that I mean
his biggest character flaw is he
believes that a lie is better than the
truth so he lies to everybody so as to
not hurt their feelings and instead
hurts their feelings twice as bad when
they find out that it's a lie but he is
a character that's not a hundred percent
perfect he's a bad father and his
journey from bad father
- good father is what the story is about
and often what happens is new writers
don't want to have that journey they
want to have the character be a good
father all the way through because I'm a
good person and this character is kind
of part of me and so they're gonna be
always good and they don't want to
explore the bad part of themselves and
we all have those we're all none of us
are perfect people we all are flawed
so you need to sort of get dig into
yourself often and find the bad parts of
you and deal with those you know
on-screen did I already say you're
basically doing you're taking the the
things you wouldn't tell your best
friend and telling you know 100 million
people worldwide that's part of that do
people can see that in themselves
that's tough thing you need to do you
need to be aware of who you are and and
really be introspective and look into
yourself and not you know there's a
Hemingway quote that a good writer now
I'm gonna misquote Hemingway but a good
writer needs a built-in
detector and the isn't for
other people the is for you
because you are gonna spout a whole
bunch of as a writer and you
are gonna give us the perfect version
and you are gonna give us the I'm
flawless version and that's your
you need to cut out your
and get to the reality which is
ugly and we don't ever want to think
about it but we're flawed people and
those flaws are gonna somehow come out
on the screen one of the interesting
thing is our story choice always comes
from whatever's inside of us so I think
it's interesting when it you know I'm a
high concept guy I come up with a bunch
of ideas and every idea I come up with
is me and part of the job once I come up
with a high concept is to go to trace it
back and go why is that me and once I
find why it's me then I can explore that
in the script better than just do the
surface version and I think bad
high-concept movies are just the surface
you know what you know what if he's an
alien what if he's whatever and it's
like it's the surface story not the
internal story in the internal story is
what makes it human and what makes the
audience relate to it so my total said
about the reincarnated murder victim
twelve-year-old
girl and that story is called past lives
and it deals with not being able to
escape your past and your past is that
thing that's always a part of you and I
think all of us try to bury elements of
our past you know we go oh I'm you know
I did this stupid thing once oh I made a
mistake that ruined my life was telling
this person they were an idiot when in
fact if I just kissed their ass you know
and all these things that we do and
there are baggage that we carry with us
that baggage that we carry with us is
why we come up with ideas sometimes we
look through our the filter of our lives
and find the idea that's interests us
and then come back and if we just take
the high concept version murder victim
is reincarnated as as 12 years old the
murder victim starts to bleed through
you could do the worst movie in the
world with that but what I decided to do
is really look at how our past affects
our present and how sometimes things
that we wish we could shake off from our
past just hang on to us no matter what
we do the whole idea of revenge against
the person that killed you is your past
controlling you so you know once you
sort of you cope with a high concept
idea then you backtrack it and go how is
this me how is this my personal story
and how can I use that mind the personal
story to make it the more emotional
version of that story instead of the
plastic Hollywood version which it may
become later on anyway do you think that
somebody under 35 would have a lot to
pull from yeah sure and and some again I
can't I don't even know who the writer
was but some famous damn writer said by
the time you're 18
you've had enough heartbreaks and stuff
happened to you that you can write a
bunch of novels and all it is is but you
know you you know that when I was in
kindergarten and you know I desperately
wanted to kiss Debbie Mauro and she
completely rejected me real name you
know that's you know that's one of those
things were like a home and my heart was
broken forever and you go through that
heartbreak I was in kindergarten I was 5
years old and I've experienced
heartbreak so if you're 18 years old you
know if you're 15 years old
you you have material to work on yeah
you know you just have to be honest
enough to mine that material right
although I think you know the older you
get the better your screenwriter you are
Hollywood are you listening
you